[موسيقى]
ليس كل الطعام الذي يتم
حصاده وبيعه في الأسواق أو المطاعم ينتهي به
الأمر على طبق شخص ما في الولايات المتحدة ، حيث
يتم التخلص من 40 بالمائة من الإمدادات الغذائية ،
ومعظمها سيصل إلى
مكبات النفايات حيث يؤدي في النهاية إلى
تعفن غاز الميثان  غاز أقوى بـ 25
مرة من ثاني أكسيد الكربون عندما يتعلق الأمر
بحبس الحرارة في الغلاف الجوي إذا
كانت نفايات الطعام الدولية
هي السبب الرئيسي الثالث
لانبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري بعد الولايات
المتحدة والصين ،
وتأتي بعض هذه النفايات من
متاجر البقالة حيث  غالبًا ما ينتهي الأمر بالطعام غير المباع
في القمامة في جميع أنحاء العالم ، حيث تقوم متاجر البقالة العالمية
بإلقاء ما يقدر بنحو 133
مليون طن من الطعام كل عام ، حيث
يرمي المتجر المتوسط في أي مكان ما بين خم
ة إلى عشرة آلاف دولار من ال
عام كل يوم تر
د شركة بدء التشغيل الكندية أن
تغير  أن العمل مع محلات السوبر
ماركت تبيع الشركة البقالة التي
تقترب من بيعها حسب التاريخ قبل
طرحها لجذب العملاء
علامة الطعام السريع  انخفض عدد العناصر بنسبة تصل
إلى 50 في المائة من المدخرات التي يمكن أن
تضيف حقًا بعض أفضل المتسوقين لدينا إلى توفير
عشرات الآلاف من الدولارات التي
يستخدمها المتسوقون لمعرفة
العناصر المتاحة لهم في المتاجر القريبة
والمنتجات الأكثر شيوعًا
وفقًا لـ  الشركة عبارة عن فواكه
وخضروات ، ولحوم ومأكولات بحرية عادةً
يوم أو يومين من بيعها بالتمور
ولكنها لا تزال طازجة وجيدة تمامًا
للأكل ، فنحن في الواقع نحدد
ما سيأكله الناس على العشاء بناءً على
ما هو متاح من خلال الوجبات السريعة
، سيصبح هذا تقريبًا  البحث عن الكنز
حيث ينقرون على المتاجر
ويرون ما هو متاح ومعرفة الصفقة
التي يمكنهم
الحصول عليها من البقالة يمكن الحصول عليها من
خزانة طعام فلاش مثل هذه الموجودة
في سوبر ماركت عملاق في وسط
بنسلفانيا أحد 1200
موقع للشركة  في جميع أنحاء كندا والولايات
المتحدة ، دائمًا ما تقوم محلات البقالة بوضع علامة
على المنتج إلى أسفل كلما اقترب
من تاريخ انتهاء الصلاحية ولكن
ما لا يمكنك فعله هو  فهرستها حقًا
وطرحها بطريقة يمكن للعملاء من
خلالها رؤية ما هو طازج اليوم ، كان طعام الفلاش
مبتكرًا تمامًا ووضع كل
ذلك في تطبيق واحد حيث يمكن
للعملاء رؤية التنوع المختلف
الذي نشرته الشركة العملاقة
للوجبات السريعة في جميع  187 متجر بقالة
في الولايات المتحدة حتى الآن ، قمنا بتحويل
700000 رطل من إعادة تدوير الأطعمة أو
مقالب القمامة ،
ويقول إجمالي المواد الغذائية السريعة إنها حولت
أكثر من 30 مليون رطل من المواد الغذائية التي
كانت ستنتهي في مقالب القمامة مما يوفر
للعملاء 90 مليون دولار في نفس الوقت
الوقت ولدينا خطط لمواصلة
توسعها ،
نحن على استعداد للعمل مع أي شركاء
بأي صفة لأننا نواصل توسيع نطاق
هذه مشكلة كبيرة ويستغرق
حلها قرية ونحن
منفتحون ومتحمسون لمواصلة القيام بذلك
في جميع أنحاء أمريكا